I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
you know like the old gladiator days I
thought that winning came with home runs
and big contracts and World
Championships and what I realized after
being you know knocked on my ass by my
wrongdoing and my stupidity that turning
the lens inward and pressing the pause
button allowed me to look at things from
a different way and that winning really
was about being a great father a great
partner and in a great leader to to our
team
I would like to dive into that if
possible to understand you know
emotionally how you felt and then after
the suspension you've talked about it
being a paradigm shift for you and like
what happened right we have to the only
way to the other side is through mm-hmm
so what did you go through well I think
for one what I've learned is that and
I'll tell you what I went through is
that you're an average of the five
people you surround yourself with the
most right amen and when I realized
every time I screwed up in a big way I
did it by myself
any time I did anything that meant
anything I did it with great people
around me and you know you find yourself
in a situation and you make mistakes and
then you how you handle that mistakes
makes it that much worse oh I made a
mistake and then I doubled down and
wasn't clear about my message and really
did I have the tools to even communicate
what I was going through at the time and
at some point I'll get a chance to to
talk about everything maybe in detail
maybe not but the big picture that I'm
ready to tell you here is that I made
mistakes I double down and as a result
of that I served the longest suspension
in Major League Baseball history for
peds and while I was hoping it was a
50-game suspension like the other you
know 15 or so guys it was 211 for the
same penalty and it that just literally
took me to my knees and tears and said
oh my god I just come
[ __ ] up my entire life and I'm gonna
play again 100% I mean new baseball was
done it was the darkest time of my
entire life what did that look like I
mean I remember when I got the call and
two eleven got reduced to 162 which is
our entire season in baseball and when
Tony Clarke from the Union called I went
down to one knee to knees in my home in
Miami Beach I was there by myself I was
waiting for that call that you never
want to get and it rang three times and
I picked up the phone and I said hello
and we were on the phone for two minutes
and it felt like two hours and Tony says
alex is 162
and immediately the minute he said that
like at tears coming out my eyes
and I went down to my knee to my knees
and just like oh my god it's it's over
what have I done to myself
and at that point I was still kind of in
denial as his fall does this fall is not
you know I think that was part of the
problem denial about it that was the
entire problem about who was responsible
for it really all of it all of it the
answer is yes it was my fault in every
way and that's what I've learned I going
back to that house I want to tell you
this because this part is important for
three weeks I basically didn't leave my
house you know a couple weeks I was just
so sad I didn't see my daughter's Wow I
was sick to my stomach I would wake up
in the middle of the night like in tears
and going like I'm the only jackass that
has pocket aces that finds a way to lose
his [ __ ] hand is so painful and you
know try to grow a beard it couldn't
yeah and then that's it the entire year
allowed me to put a plan together to
come back so you have plenty of time
reflect um maybe even figured it out in
the three weeks after I'm not sure I
don't know but did you look back and
figure out like could you identify what
it was that drove you to feel like you
could do what you
and get away with it or that you should
do it or you needed to do it or were you
able to like nail down what personality
trait or what pattern you were repeating
mm-hmm that you had to escape mm-hmm
well I think what would the 162 allowed
me to do it allowed me to press the
pause button and turn the lens inward
and start to dig in and some of the
questions you asked right yeah and I
wanted to know what the hell happened
between age 5 and 12 that made me do all
these stupid things and self-destruct I
mean think about it I had hundreds of
millions of dollars guaranteed whether I
played another game or not it's like
crazy right it's crazy and it's so
upsetting and what I realized all in all
is that I was flawed and and these
mistakes were from your youth yeah and
and look the one thing is that realize
I'm still I still do my work with in
therapy and and that's a journey that's
never gonna stop sure and it allowed me
to look at the world in a different
place that I am grateful to be one of
750 major league players that I'm
grateful to be a New York Yankee that
I'm grateful to have George Steinbrenner
bring me to New York and then I [ __ ]
it up and I disappointed and there's no
excuses and once I own that and once I
looked in the mirror and said it was you
and not the handler at the PR not not
wrong my attorney it was me
me to stop making excuses for yourself I
actually for the first time and that I
ended up seeing a little bit of light at
the end of the tunnel it was it was a
little light but it was a light it's a
crack and then it opens up
you